here on overtime and now we're gonna ask
the questions that the people on the
internets have been typing ah Lisa
here's one for you I've ever experienced
the more hostile environment toward
environmentalists than now
I do think that what we're seeing is
unprecedented and I think that what
amazes me the most is that the people
aren't where the attackers are you know
75% of Americans poll after poll say
that they want EPA to do its job and
they don't want politicians to tell them
what's healthy and safe for when you
were a young girl did you say I want to
be a pollution fighter yeah absolutely
and you know I always one of the things
we talk about a lot of EPA is that the
environment is broader than the
conservation movement important as it is
that spawned it that people of color now
need to understand that when you talk
about asthma it's one in twelve and in
the population it's one in seven in
puerto ricans it's one in eight or nine
in african-americans so when we talked
earlier about your air is my air it it
disproportionately impacts people who of
course can least afford to pay for the
healthcare they'll need all of that is a
burden on society but why Puerto Ricans
[Laughter]
I think it's something I don't know I'm
not a medical doctor but I know that one
of the things that we're working hard on
is trying to figure out how to stop the
air pollution that causes their attacks
especially among Puerto Ricans where
there are environmental causes for
things and then you've lost access to
health care then you end up having the
diseases that are caused by
environmental pollutants right I mean if
you probably can't anyway I was just
gonna say you probably can't spell that
out like that because you're the EPA
Administrator and somebody will attack
you as a Sharia law proponent for saying
it
actual statistics one in seven one in
seven and it costs all of us it is not a
Puerto Rican problem it costs each and
every one of us when that happens okay
do you think that T beggars will ever
get it that they're part of the 99% no
any question that starts with you think
T beggars will ever get it I don't even
need to read the rest of the card
anyone who names themselves after a gay
sex act doesn't get it do you think the
demise of Obama's long term health care
program will affect his 2012 campaign I
didn't realize his long term health care
program was in demise long-term care
provision I think it was too expensive I
think if anything I mean it's an
important problem needs to be addressed
if anything I think it might help him
slightly because he's able to say listen
yeah you know the parts of my plan had
turned out not to work I was reasonable
I got rid of him you can trust me in
another term I mean you know the
Constitution United States was not
perfect on first draft that's why we
have amendments you know they even those
brilliant founding fathers we're like oh
[ __ ] we left like Obama will be running
in avoid that it's a referendum on him
yay or nay right the Republicans are
going to have to put up somebody who is
a reasonable alternative and I don't
think there is one in the race so then
if the reason if the alternative is not
reasonable then he might not be getting
the approval ratings numbers that he
wants but he'll be reelected it's gonna
be Mitt Romney and Mitt Romney you know
some people knowing my religious and
tippet they say you know Mitt Romney is
a Mormon aren't you worried I am not the
least bit worried about mid Mormon being
a Mormon because it is showed that he
will do a 180 on absolutely anything
this trust me the second Mitt Romney
gets into office he will institute the
jobs plan that he is fighting so
ferociously against right now he has
proved that he has absolutely no beliefs
and that will be his greatest asset do
you think dude do you think that Romney
can beat Obama I you know I do think
Romney could beat oh I don't think he
will I know that I hear a lot of people
say well you know no president has ever
won reelection with unemployment over
some 1% yeah until it happens the first
time right nothing happened you know
everything is a rule until the rule
changes and I think this could be the
election where the rule changes I think
unemployment will be high and I think a
bomber will be the first president to be
miraculously reelected with high
unemployment because things change and
rules get rewritten inspire passion who
Matt Romney and if he can't inspire
passion in the electorate and he's not
gonna be able to unseat an incumbent
well slightly that Obama can inspire a
whole lot of passion either this time
around no offense but you know you look
at his base and they've been falling
away and you have these Occupy Wall
Street protesters who most of whom I
imagine would have been Obama voters in
2008 he's got he's got a difficult units
but they're changing I mean in the last
few months you know I feel like I don't
know if you had a big meeting there at
the White House and said okay we have a
new strategy but since he's been going
around the country standing under
bridges and saying we got to fix this
and this unemployment guy could be the
one to do it and really being in their
face and taking it to them in their own
districts and not being mr. conciliatory
I think he's become more popular people
like it better
I think you're right you're on your own
version of that kind of tour are you not
sure you know this idea too dirty to
fail is my way of saying right people
let's look at what's happening in
Washington my hope is still that the
environment will will come out of the
political realm and we'll really talk
about jobs the things the American
people want to talk about the thing that
the president is trying to get everybody
to work on in Washington and I do think
that the president's made it clear that
he's gonna offer a real choice to the
American people a vision forward for
this country that's built on clean
energy that's built on moving forward
thinking about where we need to be in
the future and you know my hope is that
the environment won't be part of that
debate because it shouldn't be right
right there are lots of other very clear
choices also it seems like you you guys
have just gotten the memo that for the
American people to get behind you you
need a lot of just repetition you just
really got to get it through their thick
skulls over and over that's what the
Republicans do they say the same thing
over and over the Republicans see
something that's polling at you know 85
percent approval rating and they go yeah
wouldn't get it down to 50 yeah they
like the public option they won't like
it in six months cuz every one of us
will go out there every day and we will
say it over and over and over they're
taking away your freedom of some other
[ __ ] they'll make up and they will
they will move the polls the Democrats
do the opposite they were afraid of the
polls and I feel like now maybe they're
talking kind of getting that thing that
you go out there every day you stay on
message and you can the people they
don't wrong as your lousy economy that
isn't as susceptible to moving polls
around as it is for some other issues I
mean that's that's sort of the big
albatross I mean I think that the best
hope that Obama has is that whoever the
Republican nominee is reflects the kinds
of positions that they're taking these
debates you know wildly anti unemployed
Pro Wall Street anti environment that
sort of thing that's that's what you
need to do right now to win the
Republican nomination that's that's
probably not a viable general election
strategy I think the other thing that
Obama is doing an addition to just
talking about the kind of
agenda that you were describing I think
that's that was sort of where he was at
for the whole first term well what's
happened in the last couple of months
that you're identifying is that he is
talking about why people don't feel like
politics is working what you're
describing about how even if you can't
motivate people to want to do something
even if you can get people to agree
wildly on something that needs to be
done there is still this frustration
that the political system will never get
it done and what he started doing is
being more confrontational about naming
what's broken in politics and saying you
know what this guy this guy is whose
district that we're in whose bridge
abuts the side of the river where he's
the member of Congress he's voting no on
this and that's a problem and you need
to call him and naming that it is
empowering because it lets people know
that it's not just going to this void
your anger and frustration or even your
hope but there is a way to move things
forward practically I think he got over
this idea he had at the beginning that
he could make everybody like him
including the Conservatives and and I
mean you do you notice and you see a
change in him and I also think we were
busy doing a little thing he was
governing I mean there was there's been
tremendous progress on a range of policy
issues he was gonna talk about him and I
think he is going to talk about them in
a way the other thing in it and I think
Rachel you're absolutely right he's
where the people are the people want to
talk about jobs they want to talk about
a sensible solution on debt and the
people want to talk about having an EPA
that works every poll shows that elected
representatives inside that beltway are
listening to somebody but it doesn't
seem to be their constituents it seems
to be people with big
[Applause]